if space is expanding WTF is surrounding
space for it to expand into it doesn't
expand to end anything everything is
just spreading apart and what keeps it
from spreading apart are sources of
gravity like stars and planets like
where is it all going into what does
this even mean put it simply nobody
knows but maybe you'll be the astronomer
that figures it out
[Music]
from shube Gautam 52 will AI replace
lawyers you probably don't want an AI
lawyer anytime soon a lawyer is not just
simply a machine that knows what the law
is a lawyer is a person with
theoretically years of expertise that
can help you strategically to achieve
your goals and that's not something that
AI is well positioned to replace anytime
soon what I suspect is going to happen
is that AI is going to make a lot of the
drudgery of practicing law way easier
and it will allow lawyers to focus on
the really value-add stuff and allow
them to think strategically and to
better represent their clients in the
future so I welcome our AI overlords the
next question comes from Hassan babanji
can light bend around corners if yes or
no give one reason yes light can bend
around corners in fact that's why we
have glass inside your glasses when
light goes into glass it slows down
slightly because it slows down it
deviates from a straight line and that's
why we have your glasses telescopes
microscopes because glass bends light
also gravity can bend light as Einstein
showed us and we can actually see the
bending of light as it goes around a
Galaxy then the next question is can you
bend like completely around an object so
the object becomes invisible and the
answer is yes it's well within the laws
of physics that if you could govern the
atomic structure of glass then light
would bend in a way such that it would
completely go around an object so
anything inside that object becomes
invisible one day we will build a
metamaterial out of nanotechnology that
will bend visible light so that anything
inside that capsule will become
invisible Harry Potter watch out at Iggy
salt masks what happens when you travel
faster than the speed of light you can't
you can't travel faster than the speed
light I'm sorry you just can't you see
as you get faster and faster as you
approach the speed of light you have
more energy and in relativity energy
takes more work to accelerate so you end
up requiring an infinite amount of
energy in order to travel faster than
the speed of light and so it's just
forbidden at Nino clutch asks Spider-Man
is so raw maybe we should try that DNA
biotech cross gene splicing well I'm not
sure we're going to see Spider-Man
anytime soon but there is a lot of
interest from biotech companies and
academic labs to understand spider silk
which is five times stronger than steel
spider silk is very biocompatible very
good for wound healing especially for
wounds of the eye and the brain and
there's been many efforts to engineer
spider silk outside of spiders to make
it in a recombinant way meaning not in
spiders but in other organisms like
bacteria or plants probably the best
known example of a recombinant protein
is insulin this has helped millions of
people across the last four decades
since the first insulin was produced in
bacteria next question what do you think
how will our future cities look like a b
or city any highly Advanced city is
going to need to make sure that there is
an integration of green spaces not only
for oxygen but just for our enjoyment
and well-being the more that we get rid
of our natural green spaces the less
we're able to have that oxygen naturally
generated in our environment I see that
they're all high vertical structures and
that really speaks to the fact that
we're going to need to get more and more
comfortable with building up because
building out isn't going to always be an
option at pristine Martian asks how far
away is superhuman intelligence with a
brain computer interface currently we
are fairly close to having brain
computer interfaces really help a
process called neuroplasticity in the
brain and neuroplasticity is the brain's
normal process to learn and
to the outside world I think that's
something that we're going to likely see
within the next several years the idea
of having a Bluetooth implant in the
brain that helps you Google something on
the Fly we are talking decades upon
decades before we would see something
like that occurring at SEO Chase do you
think robots will one day take over all
of our jobs the real benefit of robots
is taking over the 3DS the dull dirty
and dangerous jobs that we probably
don't want human beings to be doing
anyway people are working on underwater
robots that can detect underwater
landmines some people have worked on
robots that can go into nuclear
facilities after an accident and shut
off different valves but I do hope that
robots are able to make people better at
their jobs and free people up to do
things that they're actually good at and
they actually want to do Nick asks will
computer programming jobs be taken over
by AI within the next five to ten years
this is such a frequently Asked question
nowadays and I don't think the answer
will be yes and I think we've seen
evidence of this already in that early
on when people were creating websites
they were literally writing out code in
a language called HTML by hand but then
of course software came along tools like
Dreamweaver that you could download on
your own computer that would generate
some of that same code for you more
recently though now you can just sign up
for websites like Squarespace and Wix
and others whereby click click click and
the website is generated for you so I
dare say certainly in some domains that
AI is really just an evolution of that
Trend and it hasn't put humans out of
business as much as it has made you and
I much more productive AI I think and
the ability soon to be able to program
with natural language is just going to
enhance what you and I can already do
logically but much more mechanically and
I think too it's worth considering that
there's just so many bugs or mistakes in
software in the world and there's so
many features that humans wish existed
in products present and future that are
to-do list so to speak is way longer
than we'll ever have time to finish in
our lifetime times and so I think the
prospect of having an artificial
intelligence boost our productivity and
work alongside us so to speak as we try
to solve problems is just going to mean
that you and I and the world together
can solve so many more problems and move
forward together at an even faster rate
at smoke away asks what is the best case
scenario for AI well the reason I work
on AI is because I think it could
revolutionize science and Technologies
especially biological science biology is
really complicated you have something
like twenty thousand genes and they make
something like a hundred thousand or a
million different proteins AI could help
us make much better solutions for
medicine we have things like Alzheimer's
we've been working for 50 years we don't
have a good answer hey I could probably
help us if we had a better AI help us
figure out how the brain works that
would be awesome AI could help us with
climate change by helping us build
better materials another case I think is
Elder Care robots so we're getting to a
point where we have a lot more elderly
people than young people if we could
have robots that are smart enough and
trustworthy enough that they could
really take care of the elderly people I
think that would be a big win last case
is tutors of course people are using
chat GPT as a tutor but you could
imagine really fantastic individualized
tutoring once the systems understand the
people who are learning better can help
figure out like where are they having a
problem at start Soul asks how will the
human species evolve the future of our
species is a big question and open to
question but we know a lot about human
evolution from looking at the past and
the story of human evolution is really
in many ways the story of brain size and
each time we've seen some increase in
the capacity of our brains biologists
and anthropologists have Associated that
with some change in human behavior that
allowed us to gain more calories because
brain tissue is what physiologists call
metabolically expensive it takes a lot
of fuel to run a brain as many as 20
percent of our daily calories go to fuel
something that's only two percent of our
body weight so if you want a bigger
brain you're going to have to have more
calories to run it and we've seen that
through time as our species has adopted
new characteristics new traits new
habits that have given us more to eat
those things include tool use and social
behaviors and cooking the food so now we
are at a period of time where food for
many people is plentiful calories are
plentiful one question for future
biologists then will be how did that
change the human brain at enterobang
underscore two will Humanity ever leave
the solar system uh probably not but
some future species maybe you know
Humanity May evolve and change where we
couldn't breed with ourselves that
species may leave the solar system not
sure where they would go or what they do
we might send an instrument a spacecraft
to another star system I could imagine
that easily we'd use a solar sail and we
give it a push with a laser be cool
except it'd be in space there wouldn't
be any sound it would just be